thank you so much it's fantastic to be
here and I also just really want to
thank Trent and Whitney and all the
organizers who helped me out this
morning so that I can be here on this
stage and it's an excitement to get to
closeout CSS comps especially because
the last time I was here on the stage I
was giving a talk which was really a
call to action and in some ways I see
this talk as perhaps a part two of that
or if you haven't seen it answering some
of the questions that I proposed at the
end so I'm going to talk about design
systems but I'm not going to talk about
design systems in the normal sense as
we're used to hearing about design
systems I want to talk about design
systems through the lens of facilitation
right and so this is really marrying two
things that I love one systems
especially designed systems and the
second thing that I've come to fall in
love with over the last couple years is
this topic of facilitation so what I
hope to do for you today is introduce
facilitation and to show you how it's
actually an incredible and a really
powerful tool and how our design systems
really although we build them to
establish consistency across subproducts
are actually actually acting as
facilitators within our organizations
and how this is super instrumental and I
see is one of the first key steps to
helping to transform our organizational
structures and actually help us build
resilient teams as well as products so
I'm hoping to have some time at the end
for questions if you have any questions
this is a really neat facilitation tool
you can go to slider calm on your mobile
or your laptop you can enter the code
CSS EU and you can leave questions and
you can also up vote other people's
questions so if I have enough time at
the end I'll take a look at them and if
we don't get to them this is a great
starting point for you to come find me
afterwards let's discuss let's debate
tell me what you like tell me what you
didn't like that's what we're here for
at this conference and that's one of the
greatest reasons I believe together so
thank you for the organizers from making
this possible
so as I started working on this talk I
came across this quote by Laurie vos and
I thought all right this is really how I
have to start this because this is
getting at the core of sort of my
trajectory in my life and how I've come
to get to this point of interest so this
is really true for me the older I get or
the longer I've been working in tech the
more every problem seems to be a matter
of getting humans to work together
effectively and it's actually not about
the tech itself right and so I started
out at the beginning coding heads down a
member of a team and through my 11
almost 12 years I got to the point where
I was building teams and thinking about
the other people on my team and not only
thinking about the people on my team but
thinking about how we interacted with
other parts of the organization and this
really drove home to me because this is
exactly what I would encounter didn't
matter how great my codebase was at the
end of the day if the members of the
team if we couldn't communicate
effectively then the process wasn't
great and our products weren't great at
the end so this issue is actually what
drove me to start to focus on
organizations and structures and I know
this is a conference about CSS but we
work together as people and we work
under organizations and really when I
think about organizations I view them as
a place which just interactions with
human beings so this became the question
that I've actually been driven by for
the last year and a half how do we
design our organizational structures for
participation to actually allow for
participation to happen and beyond that
how do we ensure that we have a balance
of the bottom up with the top down and
we don't end up with too much of the
other and this comes to how are we going
to effectively work in our organizations
because if we don't our products aren't
gonna be as great and so while I'm still
writing CSS I assure you I still and
JavaScript I'm actually also doing a lot
of other things I'm learning a lot about
ethnography
and research and to answer this question
I want to share a story with you and
this is the story that for me really
married my call to action on my last
talk which was really let's think about
the human layer of what we're doing
right let's think about the
collaboration and what our tools are
enabling and so finding out about about
what happened in Taiwan in the history
of Taiwan became this really this big
revelation for me so if you don't mind
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
Taiwan in 2014 there was an occupation
in Taiwan it's called the sunflower
movement and what happened was that the
government of Taiwan tried to pass a
closed-door deal with China and there
was this great media org named watch out
that was already starting to live
broadcast and streamed the events of the
preceding and so when they found out
this news got on the internet and in
less than five minutes students and and
citizens of Taiwan decided to occupy
their Parliament this is like in the
u.s. occupying the White House in Europe
occupying just the biggest seat of
government that you could find and they
barricaded it and they set themselves up
there and they were there for over a
month and it wasn't mayhem it wasn't as
if they weren't accomplishing anything
they actually were leading a nonviolent
occupation and one of the most
interesting things was that they were
showing the government how they wanted
the government to respond so they set up
live streaming infrastructure they held
the baits in discussions in the streets
and this was powered by their civic tech
community by an open source community by
group of people like ourselves that love
code and believe that working
collaboratively in an open-source way
can lead to change and it did lead to
change the government was in fact so
kind of embarrassed by what happened
that they invited one of the members
from the Civic tech community to enter
government and they implemented a
process called V Taiwan and V Taiwan is
a process that's used
to co-create legislation right this is
to me the ultimate marriage of the
bottom power with the top down or the
excuse me the bottom up with the top
down power and they're using this
legislation to do things for example to
regulate what to do about uber instead
of London deciding to shut it down they
decided to take this into a discussion
they use this to figure out what to do
about air B&B and how to regulate most
of net laws and so I went digging and I
was like there has to be something like
some amazing technical piece of software
that's behind this and there wasn't
there is this really simple facilitation
method called the focused conversation
method or or it which stands for
objective reflective interpretive and
decisional and I've renamed this to
something very simple
it starts with finding facts and we need
to be clear about what those facts are
and along with the facts it's okay we
need to sort out the feelings what do
people feel about this stuff and then we
can start collecting ideas and finally
we can get decisions and I think that
this is a wonderful framework to think
about what our design systems are doing
and how to go about building them in a
way that doesn't lead to you know issues
of rejection even though I'll show you
how that's how that's a part of it so if
we think about our design systems when
we're gonna start gathering our facts
the first thing that we want to do is
find out like what currently exists who
are the stakeholders what's out there in
our organization that we can build off
of and then we need to find the feelings
and this is a this is a really important
one and one where you're probably going
to get a lot of emotions but if you
working on the design system or
approaching this as an idea of I am
facilitating I am listening then you can
kind of step back right we should be
asking people how they think this thing
should work this is the time to ask
people their feelings about naming right
or how we should organize stuff let's
get all the feelings out how do people
feel about our existing design system if
we had one or existing attempt to make
one what worked what didn't and once we
get to this we can start to generate
ideas right what
what should our tooling be house exactly
gonna how's it gonna work
how will the team begin to interact with
it and then we can document our
decisions and we should document our
decisions and they should point back to
that whole process so people can see why
we made the choices that we made and we
should be transparent so at the end of
the day what facilitation is doing is
really making an action or process
easier and our design systems do this
right they make coding easier you don't
have to repeat the same code ideally if
they're well documented they help you
find answers to the questions that you
may have so you don't have to implement
it and so a facilitator is the person
that is in charge of sort of designing
this process and they think a lot about
what things can they do all along the
way to make the action or the whole
journey much easier so really design is
facilitation so design is at the end of
the day right we're trying to make
something easier mo coherent less opaque
and so our design practices that we
really are using are designed to to help
make our processes a lot easier and to
help us arrive at this point of shared
understanding Stephanie ah kayu hughes
has a great video called architecting
interactions she's an architect but also
takes things from a systems point of
view and she says facilitating is about
creating contexts that are incomplete
right they're not quite finished think
about our design systems they're never
quite finished and that's ok also
they're impermanent which means that
they're going to change and that's also
ok
and lastly they're imperfect and I don't
know about you but every design system
that I've built it's pretty imperfect
although while it gets the job done and
so the way that I like to think about
this is each stage of our design system
is facilitating a con
and it's creating an environment and
this is the environment where we can get
things done as people right and that
environment is really helping us achieve
a sense of shared understanding for that
moment so that we can move forward and
make another decision and this is a
cyclical thing that we work through on
our design system they never end where
we start is not where we'll end up and
so constantly we're just thinking about
creating these environments that allow
allow for conversation and allow for us
to get to a point of shared
understanding to take the next step
forward so really what we're doing is
we're designing the context for
interactions and I think about our
design system that's one level up when
we think about them in the place of our
organizations they're designing those
interactions the interactions that we
have between people and different
departments right this is another great
talk by Jess Clark and I highly
recommend it it's called evolving your
design system people product and process
and she talks about the different stages
that the LinkedIn design system went
through and she divides her process each
of these communication collaboration
coordination and contribution to her
represent an an event that happens at
each stage of your design process as it
matures and I would like to say that if
our design systems are actually
facilitators then these are the things
that we need to be designing for and
accounting for at every stage of the
process from our design system even
though it may change right so
communication in the early days of a
design system might be really informal
and really loose and just tapping
someone on the shoulder and the
collaboration as well might not be you
know super defined and your contribution
to allow other people to contribute to
your design system might look more like
send me an email when you want something
right but as this evolves you begin to
think about ways that you can be more
communicative with other people in the
organization that you can increase cal
operation that you can mitigate and and
design for better coordination and that
you can have better contribution maybe
your dream state is getting this to a
pull request but I want to urge us to
think about how we are designing our
systems to account for these processes
at all levels and not view it as an
evolution that happens as we get better
and better we have more better ways of
contribution it's more as our context
and our needs change we evolve our
process so really our design systems are
facilitating multi stakeholder
discussion and needs and this becomes
really really challenging in our current
organizations because most of our
organizational structures aren't set up
to make this easy which is why I
suddenly realized how important a design
system is and what it really means when
an organization says we're undertaking a
design system so I'd like to start this
section by thinking about this quote
there's this misconception of the
independent existence right there is no
such mode of existence every entity is
to be understood in terms of the way it
is interwoven with the rest of the
universe and when I think about this in
the context of our organizations I'm
thinking about this issue where we often
have these org charts this command and
control pattern even though the universe
doesn't work that way the universe is
more like this collaborative
decentralized resilient Network and
furthermore what's challenging is our
design systems are actually about the
collaborative network and we're trying
to get to that while we're existing in
this extremely centralized model so
perhaps to me one of the most powerful
things that our design systems do when
they're introduced into an organization
is they become one of the first
manifestations of a team that is trying
to work across all of these silos and
face it that is really hard because our
structures aren't set up
that so you're doing an amazing job if
you're pushing this through so these are
two articles that came out a couple
years ago one is my Nathan Curtis and
the other one is a response by Gina and
Nathan is looking at various models for
how to scale a design system and he
talks about three he says there's this
sort of solitary Overlord model that
there's one person that makes the design
system and they're super excited and
there's hyper focus on their team's
needs
I was definitely that person for a while
it's easy to be that person if you push
this thing forward there's a centralized
pattern which is a single central design
team that produces and supports the
system and everyone else is using it and
then there's this concept of a federated
pattern so designers from multiple teams
come decide on the system together and
while it is always best I think to aim
for a type of cross-functional team
where we're really pulling the people
that we need from the different
departments to make our design systems I
think that if we take this idea of a
design system as a facilitator it's also
okay if you happen to be that solitary
person working on your design system
what that means is that you need to
design all of your processes to be
incredibly open and to go out into the
organization and to find out what the
people actually need so you're really
going to be not only the developer of
the design system but a UX researcher
team of one which is really hard but
that is a way to get started and I
believe by doing that you won't end up
with a design system that actually feels
like an overlord because the process by
which you designed it was more of a
facility process so because our systems
aren't our organizational systems aren't
actually set up for design systems and a
lot of the battle of the design system
is to get that buy-in so that you can
make your cross-functional team
resistance and chaos are always going to
be a part of the process we just must
embrace it
all right and and if we can embrace this
we can also get out of it and see how we
can help facilitate the processes to
make this more manageable
so here are two I'm going to share two
design models this is the double diamond
design model which basically states that
as you start with a problem you're gonna
have divergent thinking and then you're
eventually going to define it and you're
gonna converge but then you're gonna
have an answer and again as you generate
ideas you're going to get divergent
thinking and as you start to test them
you're going to converge and I view this
as just something to accept right this
might feel really chaotic to people that
oh my gosh
why do we have so much divergent
thinking again cannot can't we just all
agree and it's okay it's totally just
part of the process and I think that as
we can make this clear to as
facilitators as people here to guide
members of our org through this it helps
them understand that there will be a
solution at the end the other model that
I recently came came into and I wanted
to share because it it really helped me
just becomes then with chaos and
resistance and organizations is this
city range model and this actually comes
from Family Therapy but the idea is that
in our organizations we've got this
state of late status quo and we're going
to introduce we want to change and so
this foreign element comes into play and
in this case our foreign element is the
design system and the design system team
and as soon as any foreign element is
introduced into the existing system it's
a period of chaos it's absolute chaos
right people become emotional they have
their own feelings they don't want to
use it they say it was better the way it
was before you're constantly fighting
until suddenly this thing starts to take
root and you can see this transformation
into an idea
and eventually we get it becomes part of
our practice and we integrate it and
then we end up at a new level right and
we're at this new level until the next
thorn the next foreign element enters
and we begin this again and so as we're
building design systems if we can really
think about ways to facilitate through
that chaos and this is part of why also
taking on this facilities facilitation
models by talking to people and not
being in our solitaire teams by finding
out how they're feeling about stuff
really helps us make our way through
through the change model so really what
we should be focusing on is the outcomes
and our design systems and not the
outputs because the outcomes are
actually what drive impact and the
outputs in a design system I like to
think about as the components right and
so you might want to have a design
system that has tons of outputs you've
covered all the possible component
patterns you did it everything is in the
system
hurrah but that's not going to be great
because in taking that approach in order
to do that you might find yourself
trampling over people right so if we
focus more on what we're hoping that
these things will do in our organization
such as facilitate conversation be that
spark of interaction I think that we can
design it'll help us design these better
systems and so it's really about
building as much as we need when we need
it what I want to say here is please
don't be embarrassed about your design
system if your design system is a PDF or
if your design system is a sketch file
or if your design system it has red line
marks on it please don't be embarrassed
if your design system isn't in a fancy
repo and has all these amazing
components that you
import you were building what you needed
for that moment in time right you were
trying to focus on that outcome starting
with a PDF might get you to a point
where you've designed the context where
at least you can have discussions and
that's really what matters in the next
stage you can think about evolving it to
meet the needs of your team and so
really again I cannot stress focus on
those outcomes really assess your team's
and determine what it is that you need a
lot of times I really think that it is
about communication and talking and
breaking down those silos and the human
to human interactions so really when we
think about designing sustainably and
designing sustainable systems it's
really about facilitating a process
which is what we're doing with our
design systems and we're empowering that
system to deal with change and this is
what makes it proactive and more
resilient and able to anticipate the
futures of what will come in in another
model
it's called Stafford beers viable system
model he talks about this concept of
auto poesis which is the idea that a
system has everything inside of it that
it needs to better itself and to get
better in our bodies this is the
mitochondria it has everything it needs
to take care of itself and to replicate
so in our design systems of our design
systems our facilitators I like to think
of it that we have designed these
contexts and we have a collection of
processes that we can constantly use and
employ to help our design systems grow
and so for me it goes back to that focus
conversation method and remembering to
listen and also remembering that what
we're doing is looking to create these
incomplete these impermanent and these
imperfect structures because that is
setting up the first environment in the
first context for our discussions and so
lastly I want to leave you with a quote
one of my favorite heroes this is Audrey
Cheng she is currently the digital
minister in Taiwan and running the V
Taiwan process and she says deliberation
listening to each other deeply thinking
together and working something out that
we can all live with is magical and this
to me is really the beauty behind our
design systems and what we're getting at
we're deliberating we're exchanging
ideas and we're trying to arrive at a
final product that design system but
let's not get so focused in the design
system and let's remember that that
process in and of itself is actually to
me one of the most magical parts about
creating these thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]